dieses max sind total billig obwohl käse
so teuer ist sebastian lüftet die
geheimnisse 50 trackern und billigen
der typische käse knabberspaß nicht
richtig schön nach käse geschafft dass
die industrie mit dem ganz pfiffige
verfahren und das zeige ich euch jetzt
in discountern und supermärkten gibt es
immer mehr cracker chips und andere
knabbereien mit käse geschmack und das
berichte ich wenig geld porta chips für
33 cent käsegebäck stangen für 79 cent
oder kies cracker für knapp einen euro
für 100 gramm
als erstes braucht sebastian gajda die
rinde wird natürlich nicht weggeworfen
denn sie enthält geschmack und der ist
wertvoll unser selbst designtes käse
carpaccio wandert in den backofen dass
er schön knüppelhart und roll ist die
zauberformel der industrie ist käse
pulver um das herzustellen muss der
gouda erst einmal eine stunde in den
ofen
beim trocknen bommel nur das wasser
verdunstet aber alles andere soll
erhalten bleiben weil der käse hier ist
richtig teuer und jetzt machen wir
richtig schönes käse pulver der trick
dahinter
laut lebensmittelgesetz reicht eine
klitzekleine menge käse im rezept und
schon darf sich ein cracker käse cracker
nennen
[Musik]
so funktioniert das nicht alle immer
brutale messer kraft die industrie gibt
es ganz fein gemahlen erst dann kann sie
das pulver richtig sparsam einsetzen
es könnte vielleicht noch einen tick
feiner sein aber ich sag mal hausgemacht
ist immer noch nicht so gut wie die
industrie das kamen mit ihren riesigen
maschinen das käse pulver ist jetzt
einfach zu dosieren und fast ewig
haltbar fehlen noch die cracker auf der
zutatenliste jede menge günstiger
helferlein die auch in der industrie zum
einsatz kommen
ganz wichtig beim fett der alte freunde
des geschmeidigen schmelz ist auf der
zunge beim fett ist günstig und einer
der beliebtesten streck stoffe der
industrie das gute mononatriumglutamat
absolute münster für unseren käse
geschmack käse aroma für den
geschmacklose hilft die masse zu
stabilisieren und stadt frischen eiern
einen schuss haltbares voll ein
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teig in die form mit
einem hauch käse sahne käse cracker
macht der produktentwickler mit ganz
wenig pulver also ganz wenig echtem käse
stattdessen sorgen geschmacksverstärker
für ein intensives aroma jetzt noch
backen fertig ich auf alle fälle schon
mal nach käse nicht ganz so groß wie das
original ein bisschen poppiger aber
schön intensiver käse geschmack
ansonsten ziel erreicht industriell
hergestelltes käse pulver ist billig und
lange haltbar und hersteller nutzen es
als schlupfloch für ein lästiges eu
gesetz im sinne des so genannten
bezeichnung schutzes muss ein käse
produkt auch tatsächlich käse enthalten
wie viel ist allerdings nicht festgelegt
0,1 prozent käse pulver ist wirklich nur
eine alibi zutat um den gesetzlichen
vorgaben des bezeichnung schutzes für
käse dann nachzukommen beim geschmack
des produktes selbst spieler keine rolle
wie man möglichst schnell möglichst viel
käse zu tiefpreisen herstellt wollen wir
in einer der modernsten molkereien
europas herausfinden
[Musik]
sachsenmilch gehört zur müller gruppe
hier in der nähe von dresden werden pro
jahr 84 millionen packungen käse für
supermärkte und discounter hergestellt
5 millionen liter pasteurisierte milch
werden dafür jeden tag geliefert damit
aus der milch käse wird braucht es seit
jeher ein enzym das sogenannte love
lässt die milch gerinnen
daran hat auch die industrie bis heute
nichts verändert
[Musik]
denn sie fertiger befinde das ist exakt
das was man auch im handwerk im
traditionellen sinn demnach allerdings
passiert bei sachsenmilch fast alles
vollautomatisch und ohne handarbeit das
spart produktionskosten
lauda ist traditionell rund besonders
günstiger gouda wird hier viereckig
hergestellt
dadurch ist der krise einfacher zu
transportieren und besser zu lagern
außerdem gibt es so am ende keinen
verschnitt jetzt müsste der ok sei
eigentlich lange lagern um fest und
goldgelb zu werden aber zeit ist geld
darum wird er billig gouda in eine
spezielle reife folie eingeschweißt das
prinzip funktioniert ähnlich wie bei
einer outdoor jacke von außen kommt kein
sauerstoff an den käse entstehende reife
gase aber können entweichen
dadurch entwickelt sich der käse
schneller er bleibt saftig und schwer
und bildet außerdem keine rinde
[Musik]
allerdings bliebe das ergebnis ziemlich
blass da geben wir packard hinzu das ist
ein natürlicher süßstoff der verleiht
dem käse im
eine werde weniger gold gelbe färbung
geben billig gouda muss die industrie
einfärben denn dem käse fehlt die zeit
beim langsamen reifen seine
charakteristische farbe zu entwickeln
was sonst mehrere monate dauert
geschieht in der fabrik im handumdrehen
[Musik]
der farbstoff beta carotin ist
ungefährlich muss aber deklariert werden
wenn also im kleingedruckten carotin zu
finden ist stammt der käse
wahrscheinlich auf billige
massenproduktion
[Musik]
maschinen statt handarbeit günstige
milch und reife folie stadt lange
lagerzeiten das steckt hinter dem
günstigen discounter käse ob sich das im
geschmack bemerkbar macht das testen wir
mitten in tübingen auf dem holzmarkt
treten an industrie käse gegen handwerks
käse im test dollar aus dem käseladen
marken gouda von freak und edekas
eigenmarke gut und günstig als erstes
gut und günstig für fünf euro 53 pro
kilo
im hoch und im geschmack sehr mild mich
ganz so cremig einen merkwürdigen
nachgeschmack verhaltene reaktionen auf
den günstigsten käse im test kann der
teuerste dafür rund 17 euro pro kilo
überzeugen intensiv geschmacklich finde
ich den sehr gut und der teure gouda
kommt gut an als nächstes der marken
käse für zehn euro 74
ja es kommen geschmack her nicht ganz
intensiv aber auch ist cremig das mag
vielleicht nicht ganz so witzig der
bleibe ist wesentlich milder sehr viel
angenehmer zum essen welcher gouda hat
am besten abgeschnitten
der edle die marke oder doch die
günstigere variante der rote hat mir am
besten geschmeckt
am besten hat mir eigentlich der grüne
geschmeckt hat es dir leider
widersprechen
wer hat eindeutig der blaue am besten
geschmeckt grüne ist mein favorit mein
favorit ist grüne manfred roth der grüne
allerdings sagen sehr dicht gefolgt von
den blauen sieg für den gau da aus dem
käse laden der mit abstand teuerste käse
im test
doch auch die bedeutend günstigere
eigenmarke schneidet gut ab
sanfte gouda oder herzhafter bergkäse
was ist euer lieblings käse und wo dafür
ball drin stecken sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mit bio essen wissen
wollt dann abonniere die zdf besser
esser und schaut in die nächste zwei
clips